The United States and Japan have been close allies for more than 60 years...
...based on the US-Japan Treaty of Mutual Cooperation and Security.
Under this treaty, more than 50,000 U.S. military men and women...
...are stationed in Japan at any given time.
They are contributing to global peace and prosperity.
During their time in Japan, U.S. service members and their families...
...create cultural and community ties,...
...and it's the relationship between people...
...that makes the bond between the United States and Japan even stronger.
The best thing about Japan is the people,...
...the respect they give and their culture.
I really enjoy about Japan.
Actually, the number one thing I think I enjoy about Japan are the people.
Coming to Japan, the Japanese people are very accommodating.
They're very nice and you just can't get that anywhere else in the world.
It is always with heavy hearts that the U.S. personnel...
...leave Japan after their missions.
The Japan-US Military Program JUMP provides a powerful foundation...
...to help maintain the personal ties that exist between the two countries.
JUMP stands for Japan-US Military Program for two purposes.
One is to honor American veterans who served in Japan...
...and contributed to the alliance,...
...but also we hope those people who have now returned to the United States...
...will remain connected to Japan.
It's a wonderful program to bring back memories to the Americans,...
...to the military gentlemen that were over there,...
...and to watch the dancers and the drummers...
...and the Japanese food and the friendship,...
...and it just brings back many happy memories.